look i'll be honest my first interaction
with lesbians we had a couple of
lesbians live across the street from us
and they used to try to sync their
lights up with the uh
with the radio station and they couldn't
make it happen and it was
crunch time it was christmas eve and
they ended up fist fighting in the yard
and one of them worked at the library
tim how are you feeling man now that do
you think it's a coincidence
trump gets banned from twitter and
social media and you get banned from
airbnb i was banned from airbnb
i went to an airbnb in the desert uh two
uh
lesbians had uh you know
uh put together an airbnb with uh
furniture that no one could sit on right
like art pieces
like i had fat people with me so they
couldn't sit in the chairs or anything
we all had to just stand out there in
the middle of the desert it was really
embarrassing
and uh we left some dishes in the sink
that's all we did didn't break anything
i mean look at this look at that that's
what you had to sit on
every piece of furniture like sodomized
you as you sat on it like that's how
[ __ ] up it was
look at that that's a chair it's
ridiculous so then these lesbians
uh i i threatened to kill them i texted
them i said i was going to burn down
your house
they said are you threatening me i said
let's just see what happens uh i then
texted him i said let the games begin
ladies you have no idea who you're
[ __ ] with
then uh airbnb kicked me off
now did they file a formal complaint or
did everybody imagine
the story i heard you followed the story
i imagine these because i spoke about it
on my podcast i said i wanted to gas
them locked them in their house
gassed them and watched them like like
pour out the windows like cats
very much like the patriot have you seen
that scene in the patriot yes that's
what i want
thank you yeah so that's where we're at
with that i am removed from airbnb
but uh i will set up my producer we'll
just set it up under his account and
i'll use vrbo
i don't give a [ __ ] and uh you know
you're switching you know those ladies
you know watch your back
put your back have the fans been
harassing them do we know their profiles
and [ __ ]
probably i don't know what my fans i
don't know what people do
i don't know if they're sending messages
they had to go private on instagram
and they had to they had to uh you know
turn off comments on the page
because they trashed me on a public
forum which is airbnb
and i am just using my opportunity as a
citizen of this country your voice to
speak freely
against these two lesbians who are
not designers not artists not
interesting uh
they are uh goofy [ __ ] and you know
we're
locked in a war [ __ ] airbnb too and [ __ ]
airbnb they're not letting the
terrorists
stay in the airbnbs they want to do the
civil war for the inauguration yeah
they want to play the terrorists want to
pay the money look i grew up around a
lot of cwrs man and we used to go
and you know we'd picnic out there and
eat at them and watch the battles you
know and so
you know it's not surprising that a lot
of those guys are still left and they
want to
you know get out and about and they have
that energy inside of them right
but um and that's civil war you mean
civil war reenactments like that's who's
coming out
to like climb in the capital dudes that
are like out there totally fields
yeah yeah take it a little too serious
it didn't go well
and also look a lot of yeah there's a
lot of you know
lesbians with the expendable income and
they're doing the extra home
you know and they have the they call
them the deckless angry a lot
that's what it is no lesbians are
they're very angry and they take every
job they do seriously
even if it's the worst job in the world
a lesbian
pretends like she's like the national
security advisor so
she could be restocking vending machines
and she acts like it's the most
essential critical job ever being
performed uh and it's just
they're power obsessed you know beasts
really
why why do you think you have issues
with lesbians do you think you would
have issues if they were
just i live with gay to gay men too i
have issues with straight people i just
i have issues with people that don't
respect me and these two their names are
jonah and mila can you imagine
jonah and mila how do you respect their
airbnb
photo is them sitting with their
weimaraner in like big hats
are they hot like i do not feel like
they're hot no but
i i just i just don't i don't want to
get too much trouble here because i
probably will get a letter from a lawyer
within a day or two
and their dog is probably named
elizabeth smart they always have a dog
that's named
after like a you know someone like you
know someone that's been through a lot
you know
yeah we're just over i'm over the whole
lesbian attitude of like very serious
severe
like we're very competent and we have
good credit it's like
who gives a [ __ ] you're going to hell
like everyone else yep
theo you have any issues with lesbian or
are they all good with you because you
look like them
first of all brendan uh you look like a
[ __ ] get it out buddy i don't have it
that's the problem i've used it all on
so many episodes of this show
but i do want to say yes i i i feel like
i'm okay with lesbians man but i'm never
look i'll be honest my first interaction
with lesbians we had a couple lesbian
live across the street from us
and they used to try to sync their
lights up with the uh
with the radio station and they couldn't
make it happen and it was
crunch time it was christmas eve and
they ended up fist fighting in the yard
and one of them worked at the library
and uh and ever since then and i did
donuts in their [ __ ] yard a couple
days later and ever since then we've
been on the rocks but
what gets me is why lesbians are so
angry at straight men
and i think that tim is just you know
like
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of you know chatter on the dark web and
stuff these days if t
where's tim sexuality even lies so i
don't even think they looked at you
i think that i thought i think they
looked at you as like uh
you know um tom cruise's [ __ ] yeah
they looked at me
i do have a wife and kids i don't think
there's a problem with that
i identify i identify as gay
in this community that we're in i do
have a wife and kids that live in
suburban new jersey
i own a family-style italian restaurant
and uh it's called rigatoni's and we're
very happy
but uh as a as when i live in la i'm a a
homosexual
and i'm gonna come out as trans very
soon
that's coming but no these lesbians
looked at me as a straight man
uh a grotesque middle american straight
male pig
who defiled their [ __ ] art piece in
jewel box in the desert
and the reality is uh that i expose them
as frauds
and i've done it to the world now i've
exposed them as frauds
as these because that's what lesbians
are they're talentless
men that's what they are no offense to
them there for the most
most of them are are grunting tim allen
you know home improvement pigs
and i've exposed them is that you can
put on anything you want i know what you
are
you're a demon from hell so when i come
out and tell everyone in the world that
i can't go to airbnb anymore and that's
not right
that's not right do you think they're
gonna catch on to you know how trump got
banned from twitter so he started
using another account do you think
they're gonna ban your producer dude now
it's gonna [ __ ] it up i don't give a
[ __ ] i've got a legion of
patriots i call my fans the patriots and
we will
i mean airbnb has a headquarters i'm
sure we'd love to get in there with some
vikings and let everybody know what's
going on do they advertise on the show i
don't care
uh we'd like to go over to airbnb say
hello to everybody let them know how we
feel the page send me in
i'll shawshank through the damn [ __ ]
pipe daddy send me in yeah
leader there man yeah i'll send thea
right in i'll come out two months later
into the wrong office i'll show up in a
[ __ ] dunkin donuts and get a brooklyn
t-shirt on hey as long as people get
scared the point of terror is always
terror yeah so
as long as people get scared that's fine
san fran that's the easy drive for you
and the in the uh
of course it's headquartered in san fran
and then two legends got kicked
out things are connecting in my head now
yep things are starting to make sense
yeah and what i don't like about today's
lesbians and i'm gonna say i'm gonna go
up and straight up and say it is
when i was young a lot of lesbians knew
about um
astronomy you know it was their big
thing it was like you know
this the the last star you know the
[ __ ] stardust of christ and all this
[ __ ]
and now they don't even [ __ ] know
their they don't even know their roots
anymore
it's just yeah it's a lot of arrogance
it's a lot of coffee table books and
hard [ __ ] yeah
when i grew up lesbians knew about cars
they knew about shortwave radios
they were they were creatures from
stephen king novels and they fully
embraced and they used to communicate
like the movie frequency with other
[ __ ] dimensions through the shortwave
radio
tell me about your life i'm a cop now
lesbians they don't know how to do that
it's all frozen yogurt and eating puss
yeah that's it dude and yeah yeah
it's all it's gotten
sad dude and a lot of them are even
putting drop like uh
they'll throw a damn downy dryer sheet
into their [ __ ] just to tighten it up
[Music]
is